[Music]
thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Peters Morgan I'm censored tonight
Recollections vary over Harry and
Megan's near catastrophic their words
not mine car chase with Paparazzi why do
they take a taxi why didn't they stay in
a secure Hotel why did a 10-minute
Journey take over two hours why are they
once again over rigging the souffle or
debates
biological male won the women's event of
a prestigious cycling tour sparking
another furore about women's rights now
the race director says it could kill
women's sport he joins me live and
exclusively as a shocking figures laid
bare the impact of obesity on the
British NHS I've talked to a fat
influencer who's cashing in on the
bizarre digital craze for glorifying
obesity
[Music]
this is here's Morgan uncensored good
evening from London welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensored Harry and Megan's
statement about their near catastrophic
car chase with Paparazzi through the
streets of Manhattan was disturbing
their account of a Relentless pursuit of
the hands of aggressive hordes of
photographers was intentionally and
unmistakenly evocative of a tragedy that
killed Princess Diana Harry's mother and
so news networks across the world
switched to Rolling coverage debates
about the merits of Meghan Markle been
given an award as a feminist icon well
they were put to one side which is
probably where they belonged
but instead
instead we moved to a story that seemed
on the face of it incredibly dramatic
but we were told that Friends of the
couple were quietly briefing that Harry
had never felt closer to understanding
what his mother had gone through when
she died there were damning details
about vehicles running red lights
mounting payments Pavements a Security
Source so they could have been fatal it
was their Security Source
but then fat began to emerge those
irritating things and some questions
began to be asked about what had really
gone on the chilling tail of a dice with
death now it looks a little well less
deadly first as New York mayor Eric
Adams quickly pointed out a two-hour
Chase in congested Manhattan is hard to
imagine
I would find it hard to believe that
there was a two-hour high-speed chase
that would be finding it hard to believe
but we will find out the exact duration
of it but if it's uh 10 minutes a 10
minute Chase is extremely dangerous in
New York City
well he's right it is in a 10-minute
Chase involving near collisions with
cars pedestrians two police officers as
a couple described in that breathless
terrifying detail well that would be
unacceptable but did it actually happen
in the way they said it did what we know
is that Harry Megan and her mother Doria
left the Z fuel theater shortly before
10 pm in a security vehicle with a
police escort heading to a friend's
house on the Upper East Side now just to
put that into geographical perspective
that after 10 o'clock at night in
Manhattan I know because I've lived in
New York for a few years it's about a 10
minute Journey maximum
but they drove around for another hour
apparently suspicious they were being
followed by photographers but I don't
know why because they literally just
left a huge media event in which the
media were all invited it's of course
they're going to be photographers
crawling all over the place but
apparently they didn't want their
friend's house to be identified well
okay so you're going to a huge event
that's covered by hordes of the media
including loads of Paparazzi why stay at
a friend's house if you want to protect
them from having photographers turn up I
want to take a secure vehicle directly
to a nearby secure Hotel like the
thousands of celebrities do in New York
City every year
and in fact as Harry and Megan have done
in the past staying at some of the best
hotels in America but they didn't about
11 pm one of the couple security staff
held a taxi Yellow Taxi outside a police
precinct on the Upper East Side the taxi
driver Sunny Singh has given barriers
accounts of what happened he spoke to me
first last night and seemed all quite
relaxed about the ordeal
that must have happened before me
so there was no because I think that
there was no like car chase when you
were there
uh not when they got into my account we
just went around the block and the car
two cars were tailing us behind us with
the camera and that was them
why if you're worried about your
security would you get jumped into a
Yellow Cab in New York you ever driven
in one of those things
they're often lunatics at the wheel of
those Yellow Cabs and that was deemed to
be
Safety and Security Mr Singh says the
taxi got stuck behind a garbage truck
for five minutes during which time I
didn't move very far Paparazzi took
pictures they're allowed to it's their
job and of course they're feeding off a
couple who have spent the last few years
deliberately making hundreds of millions
of dollars from the media from Netflix
TV series from massive best-selling
books from podcasts from endless
interviews all of them trashing their
families that's their choice they're
allowed to do that but then the
paparazzi are also allowed to make their
corn aren't they very quickly afterwards
they began moving off again
photographers internal security guard
told him to take the Yellow Cab back to
where they picked it up so the cab ride
lasted 10 minutes and seems completely
pointless according to law enforcement
officials who've spoken to New York the
New York Times among others Harry and
Megan stated a police precinct just
outside in fact until officers blocked
traffic in the area after that they left
with a police escort and no paparazzi
and eventually they got to their
friend's house
it all sounds all right a bit
inconvenient I've been followed by the
paparazzi I quite like it actually if
I'm honest uh it's when they don't turn
up that you have to start worrying about
what's happened to you
um but was this a near fatal near
catastrophic incident
no it wasn't
70 news agency backgrid said four four
photographers sent them pictures they
said some of them show Megan smiling
they do I've seen them and this is an
hour into the ordeal what's she smiling
about is it the smile of trauma
there were no near collisions or near
crashes during this incident said the
spokesman for this agency the
photographers have reported feeling the
couple was not in immediate danger at
any point and there's no evidence to
suggest they were and you would think
given there are cameras all over the
place in Manhattan and there were lots
of photographers there that at some
stage we would be shown the horrific
scenes of the near catastrophe
I look at the reporting from Good
Morning America one of America's top
morning shows along the way they
reported police sources said
photographers are bicycles are visible
on security cameras but not the kind of
Caravan described by sources close to
Harry and Megan the police interaction
with a couple lasted no more than 20
minutes according to police sources if
the episode lasted for two hours as
Megan and Harry say it is because their
security felt the need to take a circuit
too as its route back to where they were
staying but why would they do that why
wouldn't they just get in their car and
go from the theater on 57th Street to
wherever it was halfway up the upper
east of their friend's house
cynic and I'm certainly not cynical but
a cynic might suggest they were
deliberately trying to look like victims
of the media
and they were doing that after
voluntarily flying to New York to attend
a pretty spurious award ceremony in
which they wanted to be the center of
attention Megan was getting an award for
kindness and for equality which are the
two words you'd most associate with her
I think we can all agree on that and
against the backdrop of a court case
over Harry Security in the UK where he's
trying to get Royal protection back well
what better way to nudge that debate
along than this
but they made a lot of bad decisions
with their security team on this night
in New York which created the very
circus they keep insisting they want to
prevent
my advice to them is if you really don't
want to be the center of a media circus
stop behaving like media clowns
well joining me now is a former Royal
bodyguard to Queen Elizabeth II Simon
Morgan Princess Diana's former Butler
Paul Burrell and Fox News contributor
and New York Post columnist Miranda
Devine well welcome to all of you uh
Miranda let me start with you across the
pond there you and I know Manhattan very
well we've got a lot of Yellow Cabs in
our time has any of this version of
events from The sussex's Ring true to
you
no and that they've just chosen the
wrong place to try and pull this stunt
because there are so many cameras in New
York there are so many celebrities much
more important than they are and the
carry-on just fell flat everybody knew
that it was bogus and it's obvious why
they did it they created the drama they
drove around Manhattan for an hour and a
half to to create some sort of event
that Harry was filming on his phone
um presumably for the next Netflix
installment and uh and now they're on
the front page no one even cared about
Meghan Markle getting some award it
would have been sort of the bottom of
page six now they're on the front page
which is what they wanted and all I can
say is life in Montecito must be
incredibly boring yeah completely well
it isn't going to be boring we know that
from the Netflix documentary if it is
they basically walk around with a bunch
of chickens and go and see Oprah Winfrey
every 10 minutes
um all right let me bring in Simon
Morgan you've been a bodyguard to the
late great Queen you've seen a lot of
Paparazzi in your time the rules here
are much tighter in the UK particularly
since the death of Princess Diana and
quite rightly so this couldn't have
happened there but in New York you know
it's an epicenter of celebrity culture
in America I've been around a lot of big
stars New York with this kind of thing
has gone on it goes with the territory
absolutely it does it's part as as your
security detail that's going to be part
of your plan you you accept you're going
to have interaction with the press and
you're going to look at that what is
your mitigation and what are your
contingencies if you had a 10-minute
Journey Simon right this is literally a
10 minute Journey 57th Street to mid 70s
we think it was an upper east side to a
friend's house if that was the journey
how could it possibly extend a due out I
mean that's the worrying Factor because
you know you are you are on the move
you're out in the public domain if it's
a 10 minute Journey why let's not make
it a 10 minute Journey that's the that's
the worrying bit as you're going around
and around and if you don't want the
paparazzi to know where you're going
then don't go to a friend's house in New
York when you're leaving a massive media
event with a hundred Paparazzi outside I
mean it's completely insane unless they
were doing this deliberately again that
seems to be the Crux of it they didn't
want to show out where they were staying
and that's caused part of the problem
but the cat and mouse game with the
paparazzi we you know back in 2008 2009
you know that's a that's a game you're
not going to win and we realized that at
royalty protection when they the
security decided to put them into a
Yellow Cab
I mean Yellow Cabs on in New York are
notorious for being a Pretty Reckless
and they speed a lot
um but you don't know who the hell it is
right and you're putting in some two of
the most famous people in the world into
the first Yellow Cab you see with any
security raw protection guy do that uh
no no as simple as that because
Unthinkable right that key part that
security driving piece is actually a key
part of your protection detail now
you've put them in a a yellow cab with
something that you don't know and as a
security professional your response to
conflict comes in three phases fight
flight or freeze freeze is removed from
you because of the training and then you
have two options fight or flight and but
what is that man going to do in that
situation he's had no formalized
training in that role and he could be
like a rabbit caught in headlights or he
could fight when we won a flight or vice
versa that is the weakness of that
particular decision okay Paul Barrow
you've been waiting patiently you you
obviously Princess Diana and the boys
extremely well
um that Harry is trying again to use
what happened to his mother as
justification for his you know in my
view very over emotional in this case uh
over egging of the of the paparazzi
souffle saying look this was close to
death near catastrophe blah blah blah
what do you feel when he invokes what
happened to his mother in that Paris
under bus do you understand it or do you
think he's doing this too much
I think it's too much because
um I think this drama unfolding on the
other side of the Atlantic is to make
them more relevant again is to bring
them back into the public Spotlight and
as our dear Lake Queen said our
Recollections may vary as you said in
your intro that's that's obviously
what's happening here
um to make any comparison with a car
chase in Paris which took the princess's
life and one in Manhattan
um is really very sad it's very sad
wrong and distasteful
um they are totally two totally
different circumstances the princess was
actually
um avoiding the media as much as she
could could possibly avoid the media on
that night and and the reverse Megan and
Harry were courting it and so there are
two different circumstances here nothing
nothing is is similar other than
photographs being taken
um I think it's very distasteful there's
clearly an incident
it's been blown out of all well it's an
incident it's an incident which the
police said let led to no uh Collision
no arrests right and as far as they can
say you could tell by the language they
use they just don't think this was a big
deal at all uh Miranda let me ask you
about just generally about Megan and her
they've obviously made their American
bed and now have to lie in it it's been
a very lucrative bed but they've torched
their families all their families pretty
much apart from Megan's mother is now
out of the picture
um they don't seem very happy for people
who were seeking happiness but what is
the American reaction to them now I mean
it seems to me that more and more
they're becoming a bit of a laughing
stock
yes yeah utter contempt and uh just sort
of bemusement about why they're carrying
on like this it's not as if they are you
know the biggest celebrities that have
ever come to New York and
um the South Park episode uh really
encapsulated it you know they're on this
worldwide privacy tour running around
trying to get people's attention while
saying give me my privacy and I think it
it you know it stems from Meghan
markle's
um complete uh fascination with Fame and
narcissism she loves the paparazzi she
loves the cameras and that's just
the opposite of what Harry wants Harry
is
um you know deeply wounded by what
happened to his mother and he's got into
his head that the paparazzi that he sees
around him uh his mother's murderers and
so Meghan Markle has exploited that uh
that's her secret power to control Harry
is to exploit his deepest darkest fear
he couldn't save his mother and maybe he
can't save his wife yeah I mean I think
there may be some truth to that Paul
Burrell what would what would Dinah have
made him what would she say to him if
she was still with us Diner what would
she say about the way Harry has taken
his life and and what he's been doing to
his family
you know Pierce you knew the princesses
as well and you know that she would say
to Harry Harry you you should be uh I
applaud you for marrying for love I
applaud you for looking after your
family but you have to you have to abide
by the rules and Harry's rule was always
to stand by his brother and to protect
him and she would be appalled she would
be absolutely appalled by this mess
that's going on at the moment Harry
seems to be a victim he seems to be a a
a a passenger on this train and it's
going to end in tears and we all know
it's going to end in tears and I don't
want to see his heart broke again I saw
it once before and I don't want to see
that happen to him I still love him he's
Diana's boy and you know what can we do
to try to save him I'm not sure that he
can save himself no I think that's sadly
that may be the case Simon finally
he's got this cult battle here over
whether he should be allowed Royal
protection
if you were still working there would
you think that that's Justified that he
should get that or should the British
taxpayer be paying for that it's
extremely difficult everything has to be
done on threat and risk and that's one
of the decisions that was made around
that as well as the role within the
family but I think when you go down the
route of police protection being sold to
the highest bidder I think that is a
problem and one of the main problems is
there's simply not enough protection
officers right so therefore the people
that would need it wouldn't necessarily
get it because now they've been sold to
the highest bidder yeah listen thank you
all what a great panel uh Miranda Paul
Sam thank you very all three of you very
much indeed on since the next more on
the sussexes claims they were subjected
to a Relentless two-hour Pursuit that
now seems nothing of the sort and the
mockery they're now getting in the
United States
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage
you can say whatever gender you are but
your sex your male or your female all
right JJ plus he becomes fabulous
sets out this five-point plan what has
it achieved so far nothing when we say
believe women take them at their word
I'm sick of apologies
thank you
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
very beloved let us Pride they're
careful who is praying to exactly it's
just like some kind of Submarine prime
minister you're making the case here now
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
a MILF stands for mother I'd like to I'm
not going to say the next word did you
keep quiet I'm trying to read a book
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to pierce walking on
sensitive New Yorkers have been having a
good laugh at Harry and Megan's expense
take a look at this New Yorker reacting
to couples claims of a near catastrophic
car chase
is anybody want to know what a real car
chase will look like in New York City
[Laughter]
always get far
that's what a real car chase will look
like in New York City
[Laughter]
well he's English she isn't just for the
record we're not claiming it and the New
York posters poke fun at Harry Megan's
latest quest for privacy privacy with a
mock-up of their South Park characters
in a New York Yellow Taxi screaming for
privacy don't look at me I want my
privacy well join me now are the talk to
the contributors Esther cracker and
Paula Ron Adrian and in America the host
of fox Across America Jimmy Fallon All
right well Jimmy let me start with you
because I've got a feeling I know what
you'll be thinking about all this but as
a as a man in New York right now what do
you what do you make of this
well Pierce you know I am a former New
York City cab driver I drove a Yellow
Cab in New York City yeah no for sure
and the way my radio show is going this
week I'm a future New York City cab
driver as well but stick with me here
okay it was so improbable from the from
the get-go when they said high speed
chase let me give you guys some sort of
quantification of how impossible it is
to speed in our city New York is the
only city in the world where bank
robbers flee on foot Pierce
anywhere else in the world you come
outside there's a car waiting you peel
off in New York it would be the opposite
you'd come running outside you'd be like
dude I got the money and the getaway guy
would be like dude I couldn't get a
parking spot I'm so sorry okay this is
absurd on its face and we all knew it
from word one okay hold on you've been
grimacing your way uh about all this so
you clearly feel sympathy for them it's
disappointing peers isn't it because do
you believe them I have to remind
everybody that Neil Bassey who was the
counter-terrorist chief
um who had to give an interview who said
very clearly that Megan suffered real
threats in terms of her life and that
some of those people were now serving
time so this is so this isn't a joke
you're conflating two completely
different things one is is the normal
threats which a lot of members of royal
family get and other public figures and
that's a serious thing and no one's
diminishing that this is nothing to do
with that these photographers are trying
to kill them they're trying to take a
picture of two people who've been
voraciously using the media now for
years to make themselves very rich it's
a two-way street you can't just turn
that tampon and there is no evidence at
the moment from the police that the
photographers did anything illegal or
anything wrong well let's look at that
two-way street so we know that Megan
arrived with Harry and that her picture
was taken we know that they went inside
the venue and that their picture was
taken we know that they left the venue
and their picture was taken we also know
it's accepted that an incident occurred
we've heard
it's not accepted there's no internet
Journey for reasons are completely
baffling to everybody they turned a
10-minute Journey at 10 o'clock at night
from 57th Street to the middle of the
Upper East I've done that Journey many
times I used to live literally almost
where they ended up I know how long it
takes and it's the quickest easiest
Journey imaginable because they didn't
want anyone to know where they were
going even though they're in the middle
of New York City and leaving a massive
your media event they take the paparazzi
on a two-hour goose chase it's
completely ridiculous so they didn't why
would you do that
okay shouting well her answer first you
accept that they didn't want people to
know where they were and that they would
therefore being followed because people
were following of course they're going
to be followed but you say of course
like it's acceptable yes it is it is
acceptable it's not acceptable they've
got their pictures sorry if you're
attending a media event their pictures
with photographers everywhere else you
are actually allowed in New York City on
the First Amendment to take people's
pictures
if you abide within the threatening they
weren't threatening them they were
trying to take the picture why why
didn't they Factor this into their
security detail why didn't you factor in
how you're actually going to get to
where you want because obviously they
didn't want people to know where they
looked fine but why don't you factor
that into your security did they spend
millions of dollars
they pay for tens and thousands in one
picture
one picture in the Yellow Taxi taking an
hour into this ridiculous fast she's
smiling is that traumatic smiling what
is that into the ridiculous we are now
seemingly accepting that there was an
incident and
this was another famous person we
wouldn't be having this conversation
we'd be saying oh my gosh you know why
but Justin Bieber and his security
wouldn't have taken two hours to go from
here to here it's ridiculous exactly I
agree with you it's ridiculous that they
have been put under so much
you don't believe this the fact is they
put under pressure by the media that
they've been exploiting yeah tens and
thousands of pounds for pictures of them
they should have allowed them to leave
Megan and Harry are making hundreds of
millions of dollars from selling their
families down the river to the media so
I won't I'm afraid sure
they need to tell their story let me
pivot let me pivot I want to show you
this picture this is Adidas Pride 2023
swimsuit
I think we have it here
we go this is well you might think
that's uh bloke uh it's supposed to be a
women's swimsuit but that is in fact
man this is the latest example Esther of
the world going completely nuts why
would any woman buy a swimsuit because a
man is prancing around on him I wish
they at least airbrushed the Bulge and
the hairy chest I that is you know I
don't even want to go down the whole
gender identity debate or what this
person with the purple hair in the back
identifies as I just didn't want to see
the Bulge I just think if you would that
make you want to buy that something it's
a part of the person's body
most women I think are you not all into
a bulge have you have you met a woman
with a box I'm asking the question
yes and he is advertising a woman's
swimsuit is it a woman
women's swimsuit it's part of the
women's swimwear line for 2023. okay and
what's what's the problem
that a man is prancing around with full
package in tackled right and he's
pretending to be a woman I mean I I can
wear trousers oh please
let me know that's okay let me let me
bring back Jimmy Jimmy hey Adidas so
following Bud Light the following Miller
Lite there seems to be some contagion
that is forcing otherwise sensible
companies who have huge male consumer
bases from committing professional
suicide why are they doing this
well because what happened is a lot of
these corporations have been hijacked by
woke advertising agencies that don't
want to cater to the customer's
sensibilities they want to reshape it to
align with their own corporations here
in America are very much heavily chasing
social credit scores Dei scores
diversity equity and inclusion so they
know their customer at Bud Light doesn't
run into the beer freezer going gee if
only I could find a beer that had a guy
wearing a dress on the cover they didn't
want that okay but this is the market
executive trying to change perceptions
Pierce but where I have a problem with
it is on the most superficial of levels
okay if this stuff takes hold think of
how it changes the music I love I don't
want to hear Paul McCartney sing I saw
them standing there you understand I
don't need to hear Motley cruising these
days
Jimmy what about yeah what about Neil
Armstrong landing on the moon
we have a problem it's ridiculous Esther
I want to bring in the NHS Hospital
Darlington Memorial in County Durham uh
gave a form an outpatient survey to a
woman in her 70s which offered 18 gender
options musically male and female okay
good so far it's non-binary third gender
transgender man transgender woman
transgender two-spirit bigender which
sounds like a whole thing all together
big Ender I wouldn't mind identifying as
that gender expression gender oh it's by
gender apparently sorry but it's a big
Ender
genderqueer passing agenda cisgender I
think that's me I never quite worked out
why I have to be a [__] uh gender fluid
and gender it's a story in the sun
tomorrow uh Esther when you see the
stuff given to a woman in her 70s who
identifies for the purposes of of
clarity as a woman
this is nuts what are we doing what's
the NHS doing whether this was a mental
like mental health output because what
does your gender identity have to do
with your biology surely doctors are in
the business of your physical being
I'm the two spirit what does that means
bearing on your health other than the
fact that you may be crazy it was a
sensitive way of of asking people how
they are I think a 70 year old woman in
this country is going to think how
sensitive they're asking me if I'm
genderqueer gender fluid gender variant
or by gender do and do 70 year olds not
have a gender that they can identify to
you ever heard anyone ever said call
themselves two Spirits eight is
something well the two spirit is an
interesting one isn't it because that's
in terms of how you would identify as an
indigenous person so that is more than
just about gender please what I want to
ask you is I know we know what the 70
year old I know you don't believe any of
this stuff she's reported as saying wow
I have a lot to learn there is a lot to
learn and that's all this I am so sorry
let me tell you if they pulled up
on my parents even they went to a
hospital they wouldn't say I've got a
lot to learn they'd say something else
uh Jimmy final word to you on this this
is our National Health Service you can
now identify 18 different gender ways
how would you identify well I and I
identify as a sane person who sees this
for what it is do you know the old adage
that Nero fiddled while Rome burned yeah
well now with all the problems we have
going on in the world it's going to be
Nero gendered while Rome burned it's
dumb and really quick the person I feel
the worst for is the children's
Elementary School music teacher whose
sing-alongs now last seven hours because
it used to be just the boys and then
they'd go just the girls now it's just
the non-binary cisgender half-spirit
people you're there for six months
people are gonna die from starvation it
is honestly it is not Jimmy what a
pleasure to have you on Piers Morgan on
Saturday come back soon loved having you
on Paula I'm so sorry for your pain uh
Esther great to see you I can't wait to
see you in that Sports Illustrated in
that swimsuit oh people say none of this
matters it's all trivial really well why
don't you consider our next uh segment
which involves Austin Phillips riding to
a stunning victory in the women's event
as a prestigious tour of the Gilla
cycling tournament one of the most
prestigious in the world that's one
problem she's biologically male the
tools director joins me exclusively next
to express his concern over what this
means for women's sport
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage and you're
stretching it you can say whatever
gender you are for your sex your male or
your female all right JJ plus he becomes
fabulous but Richard sooner he sets out
this five-point plan what has it
achieved so far nothing when we say
believe women take them at their word
I'm sick of apologies
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
very beloved and that's a Sprite they're
careful who are you trying to exactly it
was just like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
MILF stands for mother I'd like to I'm
not going to say the next word
keep quiet I'm trying to read a book
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to Piers Morgan oncense and
transgender cyclist Austin killitz won
the women's event this year's tour of
the Gilla she's biologically male and he
took up cycling in 2019 before beginning
hormone replacement therapy articuli's
Victory the tools director Michael
engelman's the very future of women's
sport is now on the line he's since been
subjected of course to abuse and threats
but he joins me now to double down on
what he said so Michael thank you very
much indeed for joining me it's a
predictable pattern something ridiculous
like this happens which clearly erodes
the Integrity of women's sports and is
in my opinion grotesquely unfair
somebody like you who understands this
Sport and the danger this represents
says so and you get immediately shamed
vilified bullied and hounded because
that's the way this debate is suppressed
first of all how have you dealt with the
backlash that you've received
well I think on the whole it's in the
end it was kind of positive I mean I
think part of the it's a confusing
subject right
um
UCI has rules we follow those rules uh
the athletes follow those rules
um the rest of the world doesn't
understand that it looks very unfair and
in certain regards it is
so I I think we've been preparing for
this issue for a year now probably the
sport has I'm hoping that the ioc and
the UCI will step up
um and I think this kind of forces the
issue so to answer your question I mean
I think we just let it wash off our
backs I mean there is the center of this
just a call principle which is is it
fair for biological males who then
become transgender there's nothing to do
in my estimation with supporting
transgender rights I support that
completely but when you see what's
happening in cycling in swimming in
athletics in almost every sport now as
the volume of transgender athletes
increases exponentially what you're
seeing are people who performed very
mediocreally at their own sex level so a
biological male uh when they compete
against biological males they don't do
as well when they compete as biological
males against women then they are
winning and that cannot be right
it's certainly not the view for those of
us in performance and obviously we're
looking at this from the the elite side
right so sometimes Elite Sports is like
realize sometimes it's not
um the UCI has set a series you know
they they supposedly looked at uh
research done by the Canadian Center for
ethics on Sports
um review that data and said that they
felt that transgender athletes that had
transitioned for two years were it was
fair for them to compete there's tons of
contradictions in that study I think
John Pike from the UK has spelled those
out pretty well among many others
um why the UCI is sticking to something
that
really does not look fair and it does
not appear to be fair we cannot
understand and I'm with you everybody's
for the rights of trans people this
that's not the issue here the issue here
and I would look at Austin as a
performance person and Austin was third
at tour The Gila last year
um you know we did my job as competition
directors to work with UCI the USC
cycling our governing body make sure we
stick within the rules we knew I was
sure Austin would win this year and um I
think the performance even though it's a
very difficult race was called mediocre
she raised as fast as she needed to do
to win
I would say at some levels from what
I've seen in her performance she may be
one of the best women's cyclists in the
U.S
um and it's a number of Olympic
medalists and world champions have won
Tour of the Gila and the issue here that
we have is the physiology of it
um you know if if an athlete transitions
are they the same as a woman well the
question I would have the question is
you just said one of the best female
athletes in the world well I don't know
how you phrase it because Austin's not a
female right it often's a biological
male he's transitioned uh to be a
transgender athlete fine but how would
Austin do against biological males and
Austin would not be one of the best
biological male cyclists in America very
very far from it that's where the clear
evidence is this why are things like the
Olympics there is separation of the
Sexes because if you just had open
season and sex didn't matter biological
physiology didn't matter then I know
what would happen hardly many women
would compete in the Olympics ever again
who were born with female biological
bodies it's just a fact
and it is a fact and that's why we can't
understand why the UCI has made this
huge reach to make it look like it is
okay I mean there is there is some
science that hasn't been tested out I
mean the whole idea of Sciences you make
a prediction and then you do a test to
see if it proves and they have not
proven it that you know 23 24 14 years
of being a male and the testosterone
that helps that that you know stronger
bodies bigger lungs larger heart
um and then you reduce the testosterone
that that makes you a female
um it's a delicate issue and the whole
point is whether it's athletes or
sponsors or teams and this is why I fear
for the sport
it's such an unknown right now and if
the powers that be are not going to take
control to try to fix this then we have
a problem well you're going to end up
with someone like Leah Thomas swimming
winning Olympic gold medal or a world
championship you're going to have
someone like Austin Phillips doing the
same in cycling that's where this will
go and you're going to have more and
more biological males identifying as
transgender athletes because I'm afraid
as we saw with doping for example you
know once it once it was clear that you
could win and make a lot of money and
have a lot of celebrity attention if you
cheated a lot of people cheated and I
think you're going to see the same
Martina River warned about this you're
going to see people eventually gaming
the system we see it in prisons at the
moment over here with with you know male
rapists who identifies women to get into
female prisons I'm not equating for two
things but the principles the same you
separate the Sexes for a reason be it in
sports or be it prisons albeit in safe
spaces for women or any of these things
and I think the moment you start to
conflate them then it can only end badly
that's my just honest belief about this
and I agree with you I think a lot of
the sport does as well and I guess you
know from Austin's side she seems very
nice she obviously has goals in her life
and I don't know that that means that I
I get your point
um
you know I I would look at Austin and
say well she's playing by the rules and
I'm not defending the rules
um she came and she competed and we
followed the rules and but I also think
about the biological female that was
second yeah
ultimately Michael that's the point is a
biological female has been robbed of the
chance of winning that tournament and
this is going to keep happening more and
more and more as it is doing we saw Leah
Thomas win One race against biological
females in the pool by 38 seconds I
think it was completely ridiculous I've
got to leave it there Michael thank you
for speaking out because I think it
needs people in your position to do this
it's a courageous thing to do the bile
that comes your way is disgraceful and
entirely predictable but this has got to
be talked through and there's got to be
a fair resolution and women's rights
have to be protected so I appreciate you
joining me thank you very much
thank you sir
thanks the body positivity fad another
of my little annoying things in life has
reached an inevitable conclusion
so-called fat fluences yeah you heard
right fat influences are making money by
gorging themselves on social media for
the delectation of their followers one
of them joins me next
foreign
[Music]
thank you welcome to the talk that book
has done some serious damage and you're
stretching it you can say whatever
gender you are for your sex your male or
your female all right JJ plus he becomes
fabulous but Richardson sets out this
five-point plan what has it achieved so
far nothing when we say believe women
take them at their word I'm sick of
apologies
thank you
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
prime minister you're making the case
here now pop the kettle on this is the
royal tea a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word could you keep quiet I'm trying to
read the book
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talk the security team
for the Duke and Duchess of Sussex is
slammed for failing to stop the couple's
near catastrophic to our car chase with
Paparazzi new figures show more knife
crime perpetrators than ever a evading
gel and we'll be discussing the woman
who sued her boss after mistaking their
work emails for flirting as all at nine
o'clock
[Music]
welcome back Diamond figures today
revealed the Obesity cost British
taxpayers almost 14 billion pounds a
year of these patients cost of British
Health Service twice as much as those of
a healthy weight but the body positivity
movement preaches that fat is now
fabulous and that is craze is fat
fluencers who rake in cash by posting
about well being fat
let's go I don't know how many times I
have to tell you [__] I'm going to
start my morning off at the Starbucks
iced coffee
[Music]
and then I had a few mouthfuls of this
cake but it wasn't
[Music]
really that's what people are watching
apparently well Tick Tock is like my
next guest are putting the pound in
excess pounds
89.99 do you like sweets well you can
get two kilos of sweets for 10 pounds
promoting obesity no I'm promoting a
good deal 25.99 for 63 rolls of toilet
paper a donut maker from tower all of
these products have two year warranty a
candy floss maker and a chocolate
fountain
okay so I'm joined by Tick Tock star
George keyman who you just saw there and
see you again that's why I say Bargains
Bargas all right and his wife Sienna and
the host of The Blair White Project
Blair why okay listen uh Blair come to
you in a moment first of all all right
George let me guess some stats yeah if
you don't mind me asking how much do you
weigh look I'm not going to talk about
numbers because the thing is when you
well I think you should I mean the thing
is if I give you the number of how much
I weigh it's going to be all over the
sun all those trashy newspapers tomorrow
I don't need it don't need it you're on
you're on Tick Tock every day showing us
how big you are yeah and look and you're
proud of it no no no no no that's the
difference there's proud and then
there's just being positive in my own
skin and that's what I am right I'm not
I'm not I'm not proud to be fat would
you proud would you accept that by
medical definition you are morbidly
obese look if that's what medically you
want to call it then call it no you know
your weight I don't know but that's yeah
could say that yeah right so here's my
issue with this body positivity thing
people shouldn't be celebrating being
morbidly obese in my estimation but
that's the because actually it is a
dangerous condition that causes many
people to die look you've got a fair
point it is dangerous it can lead to
dangerous issues which could you know
diabetes and so on and that is an issue
but we don't encourage gaining weight
there's a difference between the videos
you just showed on the timer
no no you're in you're showing people
encouraging eating food I'm just saying
wow look at the pizza look it's from
Costco it's no no no you're not you're
not sorry you are glorifying glorifying
stuffing
that's what it is or maybe that's what
it is
why is it funny because it is funny you
know it is funny you have a lot about
yourself I actually don't find it funny
I think no come on I actually think it's
quite sad it's comedy let me bring it
well they know it is I you know it is
you know it is please I've been an actor
for 13 years
Blair I do have a problem with this
because I think it's celebrating a
dangerous health condition and we and if
you're an influencer why would you want
to influence people to think that that
is a funny entertaining and be something
they want to do
well you should have an issue with it
you know my opinion is that the fat
positivity movement is a deaf cult you
know I'm all about living my life on my
own terms being happy finding a partner
that makes me happy but you know life is
short so you have to find happiness but
what cuts it in half is being obese your
life will literally end halfway of the
length that you would live being obese
and so promoting it you wouldn't be able
to be anorexic on Tick Tock and not get
comments about how you need to eat a
cheeseburger how you need to gain weight
and you can write it off as Trolls but
it's the truth you know I've seen some
tick tocks made by him where he is
addressing people telling him that he
needs to lose weight as trolls and sort
of making fun of it and I just wonder
you know is it really trolls I mean
certainly there are mean people on the
internet but there is some truth to it I
mean I know that he is a father and the
idea that you will in all likelihood and
all certainty actually not live past 50
60 years old is an issue so for me you
know okay yeah I know hey that's that's
my view I want to bring in Sienna your
wife you've been listening to this yeah
are you comfortable completely when you
see that the statistics about obesity in
this country the cost to the NHS what it
costs the country yeah are you
comfortable about this
the way I see it is firstly just us
personally
um where we have Private health care so
the NHS isn't a thing for us I do
understand that it is costing the NHS a
lot I think it's a bigger problem to
address though I think it's about
educating people when they're young to
make healthy food choices I think a lot
of the time when you grow up in poverty
like George and I have a lot of the time
you don't have the healthiest options
yeah but my response to that would be
okay but you've managed not to
end up as George has Weight Wise and I
don't mean to denigrate your jewelry
I don't think it's genetics no I I
believe it's because my parents were
like cool hippie vegetarians whereas um
Georges were not are you comfortable you
got us a son right are you comfortable
about his current weight do you think
when he when he does his stuff on Tick
Tock are you really laughing or are you
concerned about it I'm I'm concerned not
so much about his way but more about
um
his well-being and you know yeah no you
definitely glorify it Sienna and you
guys post videos where you're jiggling
his fat and you talk about how
attractive it is and for me
a better version of myself well yeah but
George but George the point the point
Blair's making is a sound one you say
it's to get views we know that and
you're making money from it of course
but the question is there's no incentive
for you to actually lose any weight
because of that stage your Tick Tock
is actually George is um actually on a
weight loss journey and I fully support
that I think it's more like having a
laugh at yourself making the best of you
know what made me you know probably
around to your side George if you now
flipped with this big audience you've
got and rather than gorging yourself
every day on pizzas and donuts so that's
not what I do people love you why don't
you actually go on a fitness regime and
show people how to lose weight if people
actually knew what I was thinking and
what I'm doing I'm actually going to be
doing it exemic needles privately as
well but before you start so all of
these things we're paying out of our own
money we're not we don't cost anyone
anything maybe you're making out of the
tick tock a lot of money like what a lot
over 100 Grand over a year over 100
years so there's no incentive to lose
weight is it no but it doesn't derive
straight from that that's from my sales
and that's with the collaborations you
don't even want to tell me how much you
weigh I don't need to do are you are you
ashamed of it
okay final word to you
I just don't know why he would come on a
panel discussing Weight and Body
positivity fat positivity and not okay
guys I'm sorry I ran out of time thank
you all of you very much today before we
go quick congratulations to our
executive director Aaron Gordon who
originally got a marriage to his far
better half oslin darken they got
married in turkey and Istanbul beside
the Bosphorus and we wish them all the
very best from everyone at Piers Morgan
uncensive Keep It Uncensored Aaron and
oslin
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage
you can say whatever gender you are for
your sex your male or your female all
right JJ plus he become fabulous
he sets out this five-point plan what
has it achieved so far nothing when we
say believe women take them at their
word I'm sick of apologies
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV